it's very easy to dismiss Nintendo's new
line of labo build and play toys as
merely cardboard for adults especially
building the variety kits five toys or
the robot kit
suit and playing their simple games
might feel like a short-lived novelty
but there's a surprising amount of depth
to what you can do with the kit stack of
cardboard sheets and cutesy software
it's a remarkable educational tool and
an opportunity to see your creations
come to life and that's something very
special even if the games themselves
don't stand out the variety kit comes
with five different toy cons to build
and then play with the RC car the
fishing rod the house the motorbike and
the piano in that order the process of
building them gradually increases in
difficulty with the more complicated
projects expanding on the concepts
introduced in the easier ones the RC car
takes around 10 minutes to build and is
effectively a practice run showing you
the importance of precise assembly and
how to work with cardboard without
bending it in weird places the cardboard
itself is pretty sturdy if you're
reasonably careful with it
the rest of the toy cons take anywhere
from one to three hours to make each
project gives you a time estimate
upfront though it's really dependent on
how quickly you want or are able to
build them the fishing rod and motorbike
mainly use the joy cons gyroscopes and
accelerometers to control the game while
the house and the piano work using the
right joy Kahn's infrared camera for all
of them you have to fold pieces at
designated lines and lock them together
with tabs but they're different enough
as a whole due to how they work that
building each one comes with its own set
of tricks and surprises it's a relaxing
and methodical process rather than an
explicitly challenging one and the fun
is in wrapping your head around how
they're designed and function that's
because regardless of your skill level
the on-screen instructions are clear and
approachable and even kind of
entertaining between jokes and charming
asides the game will briefly explain why
certain steps are important for making
the toy cone work as well as pointing
out easy mistakes you could make and how
to avoid them
you could also manipulate the camera to
view each part from whatever angle is
easiest for you they're like LEGO
instructions with the added bonus of
being animated
which is a huge help of spatial
reasoning isn't your strong suit after
the make portion you move on to play the
games are all relatively straightforward
drive the RC car fish with the fishing
rod play piano using the piano it's more
rewarding to see how the cardboard
translates to the software than it is to
actually play any of the games at length
though they're deeper than they look at
first glance even the most basic one the
RC car has a self-driving function and a
multiplayer battle mode in the
motorbikes game you can design your own
tracks just by moving at jaikon through
the air the least interesting coming
from an adult's perspective is the house
the game there is to experiment with
three insert able and see what kind of
rooms and minigames they can unlock when
in different combinations the piano is
the most impressive the component of the
variety kit with a regular play mode in
a surprisingly deep studio mode it only
has 13 keys but there's a lever on the
side that changes the octave giving you
access to a wider range of notes you can
layer recordings for more sophisticated
songs change the envelope and reverb of
the notes before you record and insert
cards of different shapes into the top
of the piano to change the waveform
patterns you could also create drumbeats
comprised of bass drums snare hi-hat and
cymbal sounds using a kind of punch card
that goes in the waveform card slot the
infrared camera in the joy con detects
the shape of the card and by pressing a
cardboard button with reflective tape on
it the game knows to upload the cards
data into the studio UI not much of this
as a parent when you first start playing
the piano though a lot of the depth can
be found in discover mode where three
cheeky characters walk you through the
technology behind each toy con any extra
things you can make or do with them and
how the games work like with the
building process a lot of the enjoyment
comes from learning how each of the toy
cons works and understanding why you had
to make them a certain way for kids in
particular there are straightforward
explanations of abstract physics
concepts that benefit from having the
toy cons as hands-on aids there are also
plenty of resources on how to fix the
toy cons including how to repair been
terrific cardboard which is good for all
ages in addition to the variety kit
there's also a separate robot kit
available instead of five separate toy
cons you build one large one a robot
suit the basic suit consists of a visor
in a backpack with pulley mechanisms for
each of your hands and feet that control
the in-game row
the visor part utilizes the left joy
Khan's gyroscope while the backpack
works using the right joy Khan's
infrared camera and reflective tape it's
a complex project that can take three or
four hours to builds but the
instructions are as easy to follow as
they are in the variety kit and it's
broken up into eight steps so you can
pace yourself the robot kits games are
especially geared toward children's
imaginative play the main attraction is
a destroy the city mode in which you
punch buildings to dust and rack up
points in addition to that there's a vs.
mode where two robots can battle in a
studio mode where you can assign
different sounds to the robot limbs and
step and punch your way to a beat you
can also customize your in-game robot
and unlock better abilities in a
challenge mode these games do show the
different applications of the toy con
you've built but they're not likely to
grab you for very long and less
pretending to be a robot is your jam
like in the variety kit the robot kids
discover mode is the place to learn more
in both a variety and robot kits the
secret endgame is the toy con garage a
mode where you can program your own
games using its then statements you can
pick an input like if the joy con is
face-up and connect it to an output like
vibrate by dragging a line between them
on the touchscreen depending on how many
rules you weave into your program you
can make some decently complex games as
well as ma the toy cons you already made
and an opportunity to challenge yourself
and apply everything you've learned so
far it's nice to have something to
tinker with long after building the toy
cons and that's mainly because the
official games are more like demos to
show you how everything works the only
one likely to keep your attention for
any length of time as the piano
everything else is a jumping off point
and you're limited by how much it
inspires you to create and that's just
what Lavo is at the moment a great tool
for creation rather than for playing
[Music]